الى الملف الانسانيه سوريه حيث وافق اعضاء
مجلس الامن الدولي بالاجماع على تمديد
اليه ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
ملايين السوريين عبر معبر باب الهوى على
الحدود مع تركيا لمده سته اشهر
ان 15 مليون نازح ولاجئ سوري بحاجه الى
المساعدات وهو رقم يعد الاعلى منذ 12 عاما
مراقبنا ومنظمه مختلفه تاكدوا ان الوضع
الانسانيه في الشمال السوري لم يكن ستحمل
ما سموها كارثه عدم التمديد
في عام 2014 توصيل المساعدات الانسانيه
الى مناطقه تسيطر عليها فصائل المعارضه في
سوريا من العراق والاردن ونقطتين من تركيا
الى نقطه حدوديه تركيه واحده فقط هي معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا في شمال غرب
سوريا قال مرا الجزيره نحركه الدخول عبر
معبر باب الهوى اقتصرت اليوم على الحركه
الاعتياديه والقوافل التجاريه ودخول
المرضى والحالات الانسانيه الحرجه
استجابه سوريا نبدا دخول المساعدات من
معبر باب الهوى الحدودي سيحتاج الى حوالي
10 ايام بعد قرار التمديد الذي اصدره مجلس
الامن امس
الامريكيه لدى الامم المتحده لندى توماس
جرين فيلد بقرار المجلس الامن الدولي
تمديده اليات ايصال للمساعدات الى سوريا
لمده عام وليس لسته اشهر فقط على حد
تعبيرها مضيفه ان الاحتياجات في جميع
انحاء سوريا اكبر من اي وقت المباراه
اتفضل
الامم المتحده بحاجه الى تمديد الاليه
لمده 12 شهرا وهذا ضروري لشركائنا في
المجال الانساني والمستفيدين هذا القرار
يمثل الحد الادنى النقاش الذي نحتاج اليه
هو كيفيه تعزيز الاليه لضمان وصول
المساعدات الى المزيد من الاشخاص في
الاشهر المقبله يجب ان نظهر للشعب السوري
اننا سنستمر في وضع انسانيته اولا لانه في
الوقت الحالي الاحتياجات في جميع انحاء
سوريا من الشمال الغربي الى الشمال الشرقي
وفي جميع محافظاتها اكبر من ما كانت عليه
في اي وقت مضى
من جيتي وصف المندوب الروسيه قرار التمديد
بالصعب نضيف على انه لا ينبغي اعتبار
الخطوه تغيرا في موقف موسكو المبدئين من
الاليه
ان العقوبات هي العامل الرئيسي وراء
التدهور الوضع الانساني في سوريا متهما
الدول الغربيه بانها تعمل على ضمان تساقط
الوضع ووقف عمليه تطبيع الوضع في سوريا
بحسب قبله
اخرى مزعجه للغايه وهي العقوبات الاحاديه
التي تؤثر سلبا على السوريين العاديين هذه
العقوبات هي العامل الرئيسي وراء تدهور
الوضع الانساني في سوريا تعمل الدول
الغربيه عن قصد لضمان تفاقم الوضع وتسعى
جاهدا لوقف عمليه تطبيع الوضع في البلاد
الى اقصى حد لتشويه جهود الحكومه الشرعيه